Yes.
You have your conservative values moved in one way or another.
Have they shifted at all?
My personal valley's probably haven't shifted very much,
but my political values have shifted.
Libertarian mm.
I mean,
so I used to be a proponent of criminalization of marijuana.
I'm no longer,
I've been in favor.
It's a change for you.
I a couple of things.
One was just a general sense that government sucks at everything and the more I
see the government tried to crack down on things,
the more prevalent it becomes.
I mean,
people were dealing pot on my sixth grade,
seventh grade playground in public school.
So obviously like that was la.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then it's terrible.
Just a general,
a general perception.
Not only the government sucks at everything,
but you got to own your own actions and also examining more of the evidence
about the impact of,
of pot on people's lives.
And you know,
again,
there's you ruining your own life through use of,
of drugs and there's drugs that legitimately ruin other people's lives.
I mean there are drugs that remove your ability to even reason or think.
I think there are only two reasons to criminalize drugs in any fashion.
One is if there are drugs like for example,
PCP that legitimately make violent,
uh,
and then you are going out and committing acts of violence against people,
then there's a case,
uh,
or if you're talking about a drug where it legitimately robs you of your
capacity to reason.
If it were heroin,
if you're able to actually crack down on it successfully.
But even there,
I'm not sure that the proper government solution is criminalization because
we've criminalized it and it's still incredibly prevalent.
So it's agree with you.
I agree with her on that.
And I agree with you in terms of drugs being extremely detrimental.
And the other part is that there's comparable drugs that are legal and
comparable drugs,
meaning not even really comparable drugs that are far more devastating like
alcohol.
Like you could just go to any grocery store and buy a jug of whisky and kill
yourself with it.
Yeah,
it's not difficult.
And just drink laws on the books already that prevent externalities.
If you drive high,
it's the same as driving drunk.
So I'm not sure that you need additional laws to do that.
And also,
you know,
I'm not opposed to zoning laws.
I don't think a pot shop should open up right next to my house right there.
Residential Zoning.
That's fine.
Same with liquor stores though,
right?
I don't want to liquor store right next to my house.
This is correct.
Yeah.
So the,
so I become a libertarian in some ways on that sort of stuff.
At the same thing is true by the way,
when it comes to the issue of same sex marriage.
So on a personal moral level,
I am opposed to same sex marriage.
I'm an Orthodox Jew and I believe that a man and a woman were made for each
other when it comes to government involvement.
I don't think that's anybody's business.
I think a lot of things,
I think adults raised bad too.
I don't think the government ought to be involved in adultery.
I,
I'm,
I'm so strict.
I don't think premarital sex is a good thing.
Right.
I,
I've been very vocal about this.
I was a virgin until I was married.
My wife was a virgin until she was married.
I think that's a good thing.
So I think the government has anything to do with any of those things.
No,
I don't.
I don't think it's any of the government's business.
It's consensual activity.
There are no externalities.
So what exactly is the government getting involved in?
And when the government gets involved and stuff,
then there are externalities,
right?
Once the government starts to cram down its vision on people,
then you start to get unintended externality.
So for example,
with the law,
with the legalization,
my,
my view on marriage is that the government should get completely out of the
business.
I don't think the government should be involved in straight marriage.
I don't think it should be involved in gay marriage.
I think the government should be out.
I agree 100% again,
the reason that I say that is because as a religious person,
right?
Who believes in traditional marriage,
I have two.
I have to marriage certificates.
I have the one from the state that I don't give two craps about.
It's buried somewhere in my garage.
And then I have my religion,
my religious marriage certificate,
which meant among other things that I got to shoot up my wife,
right?
I mean like this was the one that mattered to me.
And I think that's true for most religious people.
The religious ceremony matters a lot more than the state saying a thing.
And the state isn't incentivizing.
There's people aren't getting married because they're like,
yeah,
I need the tax break.
Right?
So that's a bunch of nonsense.
And once the government decides what version of marriage it wants to push,
that then comes into conflict with other values.
So for example,
once the state of California decides that same sex marriage is on legal par with
heterosexual marriage,
now I'm worried about the externality of I have religious day school or I have
a,
my,
my synagogue,
my synagogue is religious institution.
It doesn't approve of same sex marriage.
Now is the government gonna come in and tell my synagogue how it ought to act
with regard to same sex marriage?
I don't think that's the government's business.
So how about this?
How about everybody gets to do basically what they want associated with whom
they want and it's none of the government's business.
This seems like a pretty good,
happy medium.
I,
I'm so glad you talked about the two things that I want to talk to you about
that I'm sure we disagree with.
One of them being marijuana and the other one being gay people marrying each
other.
Um,
so let's start with the marijuana one.
Do you think marijuana ruins people's lives?
Is that,
is that one of your contentions?
Um,
I think that it can and I think in the same way I ever had any experience with
marijuana,
no,
I'm just talking about the,
I'm just talking about these statistical over use of marijuana among teenagers
does have detrimental brain effects that have some longterm after effects.
It's pretty proven and that's one of the things that I really,
I'm glad you said that because I wanted to cover that.
But you were in the middle of a rent where we were joking around about six and
seventh graders selling pot.
Don't smoke pot when you're young.
You really should.
It's not good for the development of your brain.
Same thing with drinking.
You know,
I didn't smoke a lot of pot when I was a kid.
I did it a handful of times until I was 30 years old,
but I did drink a bunch of times when I was young and in high school,
and it's terrible for brain development,
right?
Especially before you're 25 and your,
your frontal cortex hasn't even been fully formed.
Your frontal lobe is like this.
It's,
it's,
it's a developing thing there.
There was an article recently that I posted from BBC.
There were saying that you probably shouldn't be considered an adult until
you're 30
right?
They're saying brain development doesn't even stop until you're 26 or 28 this is
why when,
when people are saying,
let's,
let's lower the voting age
16 I'm like,
what the,
what the fuck are you talking about?
When I was 16 I was a champ.
You know?
I mean,
it was a chimp in a high school.
Now when the problem that I have with many people's perceptions on marijuana is
that it's based on ignorance,
meaning not no personal experience with them.
You know,
and listen,
I'll admit I have no personal life.
No,
you don't want to sell.
I know you don't.
I'm not speaking about we should get high.
That's what I'm trying to tie it man.
I've
seen the effects on,
on stock prices.
When people get hired in this,
they don't,
they jump up,
man.
They jumped down for a little one,
a bunch of chickens jump off the boat,
then they come right back up.
Um,
the marijuana thing is,
in my opinion,
uh,
it's another one of those things where people have this,
this categorized box that they like to put in marijuana users in like this is
the category.
Lazy Stoner,
stupid,
delusional.
It's too widespread for that.
I mean there,
there are people I know who are doctors who use marijuana.
Well,
there's the Jujitsu community is a big one.
There's a giant percentage of the Jiu Jitsu community that does Jujitsu high.
They have competitions like more a party.
It's not,
man,
I'm telling you because it's not what people think it is.
If you've never smoked marijuana,
this is going to be a very difficult thing to grasp,
but marijuana enhances Jujitsu because it eliminates the rest of the world.
When you're rolling,
which rolling is like,
say if,
uh,
you and Jamie were going to have a sparring match that would be rolling,
like it's slap hands and then you'd go and you try to choke him and he's trying
to get you in an arm bar and you're going after it.
When you do that on marijuana,
it's like you don't think of anything else other than those movements and it
becomes like this very intense meditation in violence.
Like it's not violent in terms of most of the time you don't really even get
hurt.
He's like,
you get to the point,
like one of the beautiful things about Jujitsu so you can grab a hold of someone
and choked him to the point where they're going to go to sleep and you would
kill them if you kept going and they tap around your friends again and
everybody's cool and you try to do it to me.
And I tried to do it to you.
And you really can do it reasonably hard without people getting hurt.
And it happens every day,
all throughout the world.
A lot of these people are high and they're doing this Jujitsu practice in this
little,
almost like a trends.
It's like it's a straight extension state.
If you can function when you're using marijuana,
I don't care.
But you can,
this is what I'm saying,
that and perceptions are off.
I mean,
I would assume there's a small subset of the population for whom that's not
true.
Right.
Who are over using marijuana.
Yes.
And,
and that's probably the majority in fact.
Okay.
So,
so then,
you know,
but again,
it's not a case.
Same Way with food.
Uh,
I agree.
So I don't think there's anything we disagree about here because I'm not talking
about criminalizing marijuana use.
Right.
I think that we should honestly discuss the,
the evidence that for a subset of the population,
there is some evidence that marijuana is addicting,
but it's a subset.
It's not everybody who's on marijuana,
the vast majority of people on marijuana or not addicted to marijuana.
I think in the same way the alcohol atmosphere of alcohol was,
well,
there's,
there's people that are going to be addicted to almost anything.
And I think there's just absolutely people that are addicted to sugar.
This for sure,
people that are addicted to nicotine and alcohol and all these things that we
let people have.
The material addictiveness of marijuana is not comparable to opioids though for
sure.
It's not even comparable to alcohol or nicotine.
It's,
it's,
uh,
seems to be very rare when people become physically addicted to it.
Extremely rare.
And what's,
what's common though is abuse and
it's common in everything that human beings consume.
It's abuse as common as we said with food.
Certainly common with alcohol.
It's certainly common with pills.
You know,
I really believe that the way to solve some of these problems is a social fabric
problem.
Like it's a parenting problem.
It's a social fabric problem.
It's a personal choice problem.
That's why virtually every solution I suggested.
So funny and I'm constantly conservatives like me who are libertarian leaning or
constantly accused of being non-compassionate no,
it's just our compassionate solutions don't involve the use of government.
It's like we're going to encourage people to make better decisions with their
lives.
And if you choose not to do that,
it's a free country.
Well,
you know,
coming from religious background,
you have this community that reinforces this kind of behavior and thought.
And uh,
I think that's one of the major,
really,
one of the best benefits of religion is that moral fabric and that community,
the sense of community.
Even silly ones like Mormons,
you know,
they're the nicest folks,
right?
They believe something that is fucking patently insane.
If you go and read the Joseph Smith texts from 1820 when he was 14 years old,
the shit that he wrote,
like I try not to get into that triangle in Santa Fe.
I wear a funny hat all day.
I'm just going to get to that.
But you know with that said,
I mean Alexis de Tocqueville talks about this,
you know,
early on in the American republic,
the idea is that what makes America very different is the idea.
You don't need a big government when you do have a supportive social fabric
where people feel like they're at least oriented toward a common goal.
It's one of the problems that I think we have in the country right now.
I'm not sure people are oriented toward even a common sense of,
of conversation,
right?
I mean it's,
you don't have to agree on,
on everything in order to have a common sense of the important values that that
unify the country are showing us.
I always use Sam Harris is sort of my bet.
No art here because he's obviously a militant atheist.
I'm,
I'm in equally in equally strong believer and yet when it comes to the things
that we would like to see happen in the country,
not government policy level but on a let's have a conversation level and discuss
on evidence level,
we're on the same page.
There are certain core assumptions you have to make in order for that to to
happen.
And my argument about America and the West is that those core assumptions are
built on Judeo Christian foundations.
Sam's core argument seems to be that they're built on evolutionary biology.
We differ a little bit there.
Um,
I don't want to let this marijuana then go to shit.
One of the things that I wanted to bring up too was this idea that if you're
religious person,
don't you think that there's certain things that may be God put here for us to
consume,
to change your perspective,
to allow you to reach new levels of consciousness.
Do you think it's entirely possible that some of these things that are here,
and I know you haven't experienced,
but they might literally have been put there by God and there's some evidence to
say that a lot of the texts from the Bible that in particular,
there was a,
I think it was the University of Tel Aviv somewhere in in Jerusalem,
or these scholars were,
they were trying to decipher what it,
when Moses
encountered the burning Bush,
right,
and they believe that it may have been the Acacia tree,
which is very rich and dimethyltryptamine,
which is a psychedelic substance that actually that the brain produces.
It's very common in plants and they think that this might have been when he met
God and the God was a burning Bush,
that this might have been some crude translation of them being involved in some
sort of a psychedelic experience.
Now it sounds outlandish unless you've had that psychedelic experience and when
you have,
you very well could think that you were in a conversation with God.
This is on earth and this is something that may very well have been lost
information or this may very well have been rituals that people participated in
to bring them closer together and to reinforce that sense of community that you
do get from a church.
And you do get from uh,
a group of people that share more beliefs and values.
And there's a,
there's a real good discussion that a lot of these experiences that became these
religious doctrines came from psychedelic experiences.
Now,
as someone who's never experienced that before,
I know this is probably a very strange thing to try to even wrap your head
around it.
It is entirely alien until you experience it,
but it might very well be religious.
I mean,
I've,
I've heard that from other people who've been,
who've used those kinds of driving.
Sam actually made this argument to me too about the use of psychedelics and any
maybe,
I mean God apples.
Well.
Okay,
so then this argument,
I will say I'm not super fond of the argument that God made something and
therefor it's ours to use or abuse.
I mean like I keep kosher,
right?
Like God made pigs,
I don't need them.
So,
so I,
I am not a huge fan of the argument that because something is here or because in
urges natural,
therefore we ought to imbibe or therefore we ought to participate in a
particular activity.
You know,
one of the things that I,
that I'm very big on,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a rationalist when it comes to religion as much as you can be a rationalist
with regard to religion to the extent that I think that it's up to us to use our
reasonable faculties to determine the proper use of things.
So,
which is why you shouldn't overuse drugs.
Even if you're going to use drugs,
this is part of the problem making things illegal.
You make things illegal,
then you really don't know what it is or how it affects the body or what's the
right dose or the wrong dose.
And then people get involved in these terrible situations where they're taking
things.
They're just guessing.
I mean there's truth to that,
but it's also true that on a social level,
I'm not talking about legal cause we totally agree on the legal level,
on the social level,
there's a couple of things that are true of,
for example,
the Orthodox Jewish community,
low rates of addiction because people have that social fabric.
They don't feel the necessity.
Also,
you know,
as you say,
substance use in moderation can actually be quite a good thing.
So low rates of alcoholism in the Jewish community.
And part of that is the fact that you are given kiddish wine from the time
you're a kid.
Right?
I mean you actually are our de-stigmatize.
Yeah.
It's de stigmatized.
And the idea is that in its proper context,
this could be a good thing.
Right?
Uh,
so I'll admit,
I don't know enough about the proper context of marijuana to know when it would
be a quote unquote good thing.
And so I can also be a good thing.
This is what I'm talking about.
So,
and also I'm,
you know,
I don't,
the truth is I don't enjoy drinking.
Right.
I'm not,
I'm not a drinker.
I don't enjoy.
I like reality.
I like living in reality and I like experiencing it totally sober.
So I've never really felt the urge to do any of that stuff.
I,
I hear the pitch,
I hear the bench,
but I've never really felt the interior desire or need to jump into that.
I think that what we're dealing with though is perceptions that have been molded
by laws that were shaped by tyrants.
That's what I think.
I mean,
again,
that's totally possible and plausible.
Yeah,
and it's historically accurate.
I mean when it comes to prohibition,
prohibition with alcohol didn't work.
Prohibition with drugs is just making the cartels bigger and it's causing
middle.
I had no problems with [inaudible] on a practical level.
I agree.
Whether you like drugs or don't like drugs,
government intervention is generally a giant fail.
I think our perceptions of what is good for you and is bad for you is also based
on laws that the government created ignorantly,
these sweeping psychedelic act of 1970,
which made virtually everything psychedelic that they could,
they missed a few things,
few things slip through the crack,
but all of the trip to means and or most of them,
um,
the bacillus been LSD,
all that stuff was made completely illegal by people really didn't even know
what it was.
And a lot of that is why we base our ideas of what's good or bad for you.
It's,
it's based on what is legal and what other people have done with it.
Uh,
on,
on this area,
I'll admit,
not only complete experiential ignorance,
but complete evidentiary ignorance.
So I haven't examined the evidence.
I really don't have strong opinions on any of this stuff.
It's one of the bridges that we all could use between conservative thought in
liberal thought it particularly for people that are dying.
It's one of the things that Johns Hopkins found.
And,
uh,
so there's been other studies done and there's been therapy dawn on people that
are dying of terminal diseases and they give them silicide [inaudible] and when
they give them these mushroom trips,
they have these beautiful experiences where they completely accept death and
it's almost a universal reaction to it that like the,
the amount of people who still experience a positive benefit months and months
after the experience while they're dying,
that they say this was an incredibly moving and powerful moment in my life that
allowed me to accept the fact that my time here is done.
I mean,
listen,
if,
if that's something that,
that works for people and that's what it's designed to do,
then I don't know if it's designed well,
even if it is designed,
it is designed by God,
like literally mine,
that that's fine.
I mean,
I think there's also the generalized religious counter argument that there are
no shortcuts to nor no short cuts to happiness.
So there's hope let's it,
let's pose a shortcut.
I don't think,
well,
this is the question,
right?
I mean like let's say that I could guarantee you that tomorrow you're going to
be a happier person.
All you have to do is take this regimen of,
of drugs that you're going to take every day and it's gonna make you a happier
person,
a more rounded person,
but it's going to permanently change your brain chemistry.
Is that something that you think is good or is it something you think is bad?
Cause from a religious perspective,
there's an argument to be made that these are,
this is work you need to do on yourself without outside aid.
If possible.
If there's cases where you can't,
then you can't.
But yeah,
you know,
turns an interesting thought.
Experiment
turns.
We kinda had a line about that.
Uh,
he said that,
uh,
there was a joke about,
there was a monk and he met Buddha because Buddha came to town and he said,
Buddha,
he wanted to impress him.
He said,
I practiced a city of levitation.
And,
uh,
I've done this for 10 years and now I can walk on water.
And the Buddha says,
put the ferries.
Only a nickel.
It's like,
what are you fucking wasted your time?
Like you can aid the progression rapidly with psychedelic drugs.
And this is something that the,
you know,
do you know about maps and their work with Mtma and soldiers that have had PTSD
not sell as much?
You know,
it's,
it's phenomenal by giving these soldiers MTMA therapy,
meaning they,
they give them MDM DMA,
which is essentially what people think of as ecstasy.
The street name.
They give them pure Mtma and then they assist them with the,
they actually have a psychologist sit with them,
a therapist,
and they'd go over all these details of these traumatic events and they come to
peace with everything.
And they've had profound benefits for a soldiers.
And four,
we,
uh,
some combat journalists did different people that have been over there.
And I've experienced the horrors of war and just general PTSD maybe for people
who've experienced violence attacks.
That is shown to be one of the very best things we've ever discovered for
helping people get past.
So here's to me,
and I'm thinking about this on the fly,
because this is stuff I don't think about very much.
Um,
but it's,
it's,
there's a complex moral equation to the extent that if you're talking about
somebody who has PTSD,
somebody has a condition and the only way to help that condition is to use these
drugs.
I've never had a problem with any of that stuff.
Right.
I mean,
I've had,
my grandfather was,
was schizophrenia and by maybe bipolar,
maybe schizophrenia,
the diagnosis not exactly clear,
they prescribed him.
Lithium made him a lot better,
would have been better off struggling with the schizophrenia of course not it
much better than he should have the lithium and then be able to live in his
rational mind.
Yeah.
So when there's a problem using drugs to get past it and work with it is a good
thing.
You do run the risk of the sort of brave new world situation where you have a
group of people who have a certain level of Ersatz happiness that is not driven
by,
uh,
a point of view,
but more by just the chemicals in their body.
Chemicals affect your point of view.
That is 100% true.
But are you Yuval Harari talks about maybe this is the future,
right?
He talks about the idea that maybe the future is we just drug ourselves until
we're happy.
Basically a more that happiness is the drugs.
Because if you're a scientific materialist,
that's what it is.
Happiness is just a bunch of chemicals flowing through your body.
So if you can bring them in without self change,
but I do wonder that robs people of a certain level of purpose that,
that the struggle is part of being human.
I think
changing what it is to be human just by carrying around phones and just,
I mean that's,
that's true.
But I think that that's again,
one of the things that I think makes being a human worth while is the idea that
you are struggling.
I think.
I think the struggle is actually meaningful.
And I think that's why religions tend to set prophylactic rules sometimes for
good,
sometimes for ill.
So for example,
I am addicted to my phone.
I mean there's just no question,
right?
It's,
it's in my hand all the time.
And,
but from Friday night to Saturday night,
it's off.
I can't look at it and forbidden from looking at it.
And this breaks the cycle at least for one day a week.
And that's a good thing that makes me better as a human being is a limit I set
for myself and then limit that I abide by.
And if you believe in in self mastery,
what,
where's the happy medium between self mastery and I need a little bit of a,
and I think that there,
there is a happy medium in there.
Um,
but I'm not sure that that,
you know,
drugs are the answer to,
I don't think you're suggesting drugs or no,
I'm not
suggesting that.
There's also a problem with the word drugs that the,
everything is under that blanket and that blanket can be entirely negative or
extremely positive.
And Eric,
but I know,
but that's it.
There is a pro I use it too.
I mean it's not accusing you but that that term it's a problem.
It's a problem term because what these are are substances that are psychoactive
and some of them can be extremely beneficial.
And some of them have short term experiences that last with longterm results.
And I don't think that there's enough knowledge that I don't think the people
that are negative against it have experienced enough of it or have looked at it
in an objective,
rational way because I think it's something that could be here to aid
perspective,
to give people a chance to think outside of their normal conditioned way of
thinking that might've been established by their community or by their church or
by their neighborhood,
whatever it is.
Sometimes it a little bit of a break,
a little bit of a,
a mental break from what you're experiencing in the vibration that you exist on
almost every day.
To separate from that and to get a look at it from the outside.
Sometimes it allows you to have a renewed perspective that can enhance your life
greatly.